hey Sara if I know some people who want
to build a machine-learning pipeline and
to end on GCP could you help absolutely
it's an area I know pretty well how can
I help could you walk me through a
real-world example no problem
we've got a demo that shows you how to
predict the price of a bottle of wine
with nothing more than its description
and variety really you don't even need
to know the name or the year the wine
nope we can get everything we need just
from those two things give me five
minutes and I'll show you a wine
prediction model
okay let me explain how our model works
the trick to predicting the price of a
bottle of wine without needing to know
the name or year is to use a model that
allows us to extract more meaning from
the wines description we can't feed the
raw text of our wine descriptions
directly to the model so we'll first
need to encode it in a numerical format
that our model can understand so we turn
the words into arrays of numbers so our
description is in a format that the ml
algorithms can more easily use yes and
there are many ways to transform text if
we use multiple types of transformations
at once our model will be able to
identify more complex relationships in
our data well use what's called a wide
and deep model to predict each wines
price for the wide part of our model
will represent our text as a bag of
words which will look like an array of
ones and zeros indicating the presence
or absence of certain words from our
vocabulary in this example our
vocabulary includes the top 12 thousand
words from our entire text corpus of
wine descriptions so what makes it's a
wide model good question we'll be
transforming each text description into
a single long vector the same sizes our
vocabulary in this case twelve thousand
elements for the deep part of our model
we'll create word embeddings which is
just a fancy mathematical way of saying
that we'll use vectors to measure the
similarity between words similar words
will be closer together in vector space
so we call this deep because instead of
using a single long vector we use many
shorter vectors to capture words that
are closely related exactly and the
number of vectors for each description
depends on how big you want your
embedding space to be here we're using
an eight dimensional embedding space
okay I think I get it so how do we
actually train this model colab has
everything we needed it's an interactive
and collaborative Python notebook that
you can access directly from the browser
completely free to train our model will
use a TPU which stands for tensor
processing unit Google's custom ASIC
designed specifically for machine
learning it's just three mouse clicks to
change your runtime and collab to use a
TPU after we select the TPU runtime
we'll download the data and convert it
to a format our model will understand
what about all the storage compute and
other stuff I need to do this training
good point with collab we don't have to
worry about managing any infrastructure
we just create a notebook and get
straight into building and training our
model let's see what the model looks
like when we use it to predict how much
a particular bottle of wine costs pretty
good right yeah it looks to be within
about 10% for most of them you can also
run the model yourself by clicking a
link in the description and don't forget
to subscribe to the Google cloud
platform channel
[Music]